the batia skyscraper inslin czechia is a
landmark of architecture I know it
doesn't look like much by modern
standards but this isn't from the 1970s
or 1980s it was completed in 1939. it
was administration building number 21
built to run the batia company which it
started as a small shoe manufacturer and
grown into a huge multinational
corporation across dozens of different
Industries with tens of thousands of
employees and this building wasn't just
modern in style for a pre-World War II
building it's surprisingly Advanced it
has air conditioning and heating
adjustable for each floor it has a
couple of small paternoster lifts for
getting between adjacent floors which
are a continuous chain of cabins that
never stop they're very efficient just a
little bit dangerous and the boss has a
corner office on every floor because the
boss's office is an elevator the control
panel is next to the desk and we're
going up
however only the museum staff here are
actually allowed to push the buttons so
please enjoy this little bit of camera
trickery
foreign
the folks who were showing me around
didn't want to be on camera which is
fair enough so I'm going to be your tour
guide today this elevator was built by
Otis the American manufacturer for Yan
Antonin Bacha the head of the company
and the technical side of this is
roughly the same as any other large
Goods lived oaters have built much
bigger and heavier elevators than this
scaling up to 5 meters by 5 meters isn't
too difficult and the Furnishings don't
have that much weight it does have a few
extra features two telephones one for
local calls and one for International
Plus Saturn lighting and air
conditioning but those were pretty much
all solved problems for elevators by
1939 if you're running one cable for
lighting it's not much more effort to
add a few more to power some fans and
provide telephone lines but the bit that
surprised me was the sink how is their
hot and cold running water and a drain
in a moving elevator when I first heard
about this I thought there'd be a sink
installed on each floor and it would
just line up but no this moves with the
elevator and then I thought maybe there
was some incredibly clever Plumbing like
in that rotating house visited a while
ago but actually there's just a water
tank above and a waste water tank below
and every so often maintenance would
fill that one and empty that one because
sometimes the simplest Solutions are the
best these days it's kept dry now there
is a story that the boss would use this
elevator to always keep a watch on
employees appearing at any time staring
from his chair out of the door but the
guides here say that's a myth and it
doesn't make sense anyway because each
floor of this building is 80 meters by
20 meters and this is a corner office
with fairly narrow doors there just
aren't the sight lines to make that
possible and besides there's a big light
up indicator outside that tells you what
floor the office is currently sitting on
it's not recorded whether employees
would ever just push the button to call
the office to their floor as a prank I
really hope that happens sometimes
I couldn't tell you for sure why this
was built it's probably efficiency it is
quite a long walk to the main public
elevators plus it's much more private
rather than the boss riding along with
everyone else and besides Jan Anthony
Bacha never actually got to use this
because the building was completed in
1939 by which point Europe was at War
and Jan Antonin had left the continent
with his family the history of him and
the fates of the various International
branches of the company after that are
complicated complicated enough that you
could probably get a whole PhD trying to
understand it after the war he was
declared a traitor and he died in Exile
in Brazil in 1965 but in 2007 the
conviction was officially overturned and
in 2019 he was given czechia's highest
honor for services to the country and
there's a statue of him in the park just
over the road history is complicated
particularly second world war history in
Central Europe and particularly when I
just came here to make a video about an
interesting elevator this building is
now the main government office for this
whole region and a local tourist
attraction
and every so often someone still stops
by to service the elevator